together we are wild stallions
hannah reeves and alex winter joined the
san dimas high school virtual graduation
ceremony
to deliver a message to the class of
2020 in character as bill and ted from
villante's excellent adventure
we know it's a tough time right now and
that you're having to do this virtual
graduation
we want to wish you the best of luck
moving forward
yeah congratulations to the graduating
class of 2020
well done san dimas high school football
does roll rules but most importantly
we wanted to tell you to be excellent to
each other
and party on of course the two actors
starred in the 1989 cult classic and the
1991
sequel which takes place in san dimas
california
now the high school twitter page posted
the graduation video with this message
thanks alex winter and canna reeves for
making our students day
extra special so there is so much
excitement surrounding the upcoming
third film bill and ted face the music
which is set to hit theaters this
summer now the official instagram page
for the film recently posted
this pic with the caption whoa exactly
three months from today
billy kid cudi and thea will join the
adventure dude
the pick features smart weaving and
bridget lundy pink will play
bill and ted's kids and of course
there's kid cudi
now for years there was speculation that
a third built-in ted film was in the
works
the dynamic duo made the official
announcement last summer hi
i'm alex winter and i'm kiana reeves and
together
we are wild stallions and we are here
at the hollywood bowl where we'll never
play never play
oh but we're here to announce something
yes
we want to say thank you to you the fans
we do because
it looks like we might actually
hopefully make a movie this summer
bill and ted 3 face the music yes and it
is all because of you guys
and so we owe you a huge debt of
gratitude we wanted to say thank you
thank you and be excellent be excellent
okay so we're still waiting on an
official trailer for this movie but i
was very surprised to learn that
director steven soderbergh played a big
role
in bringing bill and ted 3 to life after
he worked with ed solomon the original
writer on the first two films
so he revealed in a recent interview
when ed and i started working on mosaic
i knew of course that he had bill and
ted in his past
and one day we were talking and he was
like you know we wrote a third bill in
ted movie
and i said well great like what's going
on with that can i read it and i read it
and i was just part of a group of people
including scott cruz the original
producer
and keanu and alex that really wanted to
see this happen
my role was more as cheerleader than
anything he added
the companies that own the rights to
make a sequel i called them up and said
this script's hilarious why aren't we
doing this we found a fantastic director
dean pariso who i've known for a long
time
i've seen it it's really good and we're
almost done and i feel like it's the
perfect movie for people who want to
feel better about what's happening
right now he's also one of the executive
producers on the film
so tell me how excited are you for bill
and ted face the music because i am so
freaking excited
let me know in the comments below